my guest this week is a speaker and
author and host of the factual feminist
on YouTube she's known as bass mom by
the gamergate gang and just finished a
three hour conversation with Joe Rogan
so I hope you have a little something
left christina hoff sommers welcome to
the show lovely to be here do you have a
little something left I do I do I'm just
getting started
yeah see I was did three did you go a
little over where were you with your
brain just three in his little man cave
there it was a very cozy little studio
well right before we sat down we were
saying how there's this new gang sort of
that has appeared sort of you Joe Milo
me a few other people that sort of have
magically connected even though just
months ago we really didn't know each
other and yet we're all talking about a
lot of the same stuff it's pretty cool
right right and I think that what we are
is we're rejecting the cultural
authoritarians and so we come from
different political places but we share
this commitment to freedom and you know
just live and let live what happened to
that what happened to that alright so I
want to spend a lot of time talking
about the cultural libertarians and the
authoritarians and all of that alright
Aaron but first let's start somewhere
else let's start with based mom because
that's the phrase that popped up many
times and I see people tweeting this any
time I'm involved in a Twitter thing
with you bass mom what is what does that
actually mean for the person that
doesn't first I thought it meant cool
mom yeah and I was happy with that but
it turns out it means something very
positive and just as good but different
in the lingo of the gamers and I don't
maybe they got it from a rap song or
something but based means grounded
authentic no BS yes they would say and
so that's what I am and I'm happy to be
based mom I like being a mom which I am
and being based is obviously a good
things yeah there you go all right so so
let's start with the factual feminist
let's go there first I want to do a
little history of feminism but what
brought you personally to be doing these
types of videos and talking about this
stuff just your journey a little bit
well I've always been a I was a
professor for many years and wrote
school scholarly articles and books and
I wasn't doing videos on YouTube
I thought that was at the time I thought
it was about I don't know cats it's
still mostly I said it's still mostly
kids yeah
and but this young man came to a e.i and
wanted to get the scholars on the air he
did videos with all of us and then he
came to me and said you we want to put
you I want you to have a weekly show
just come and talk and I said about what
what are you talking about and he said
and it's in no more than five minutes
preferably four yeah and how do I do
that
but I started to do it I thought okay
once a week approximately I will go on
and correct a feminist myth because
there are so many and I just wanted the
opportunity to reason with people to
analyze some of these factoids fickt
euch we are in it inundated with MS
information if you excuse the pun just
false information about women they tend
to exaggerate they these researchers
slash activists tend to exaggerate
women's vulnerability and to overstate
the strengths of men when in fact it's a
complicated mix of benefits and burdens
for both sexes and so when they say Oh
women are being cheated out of 23
percent on the dollar and well for being
sexually assaulted it just turns out
these are ridiculous exaggerations and
the truth is entirely different and so I
just patiently try to you know expose
the myths when I first started my mother
said well darling aren't you going to
run out of topics I said well I will
never run out of topics because we have
had going on you know three decades of
specious research coming out of gender
studies and it all needs to be
reconsidered some of it might be right I
occasionally I find something it's not
you know bins just twisted into a myth
and so I I correct a myth every week
yeah so before we dive right into the
feminist of how do you like being in
this space because obviously it is new
to you to be in the YouTube space and
interacting with people like better and
Twitter and all that gamers I've never
expect really yeah I mean
ever expect to be sort of a hero to the
gamergate community I want to talk about
that later too but just being in this
interesting digital new thing no no I
didn't think I would I remember a few
years ago before I was on Twitter I said
oh I'll never do that I don't know how
to do that I just it was unapproachable
well now I can't get off it's so
addicting yeah but I didn't expect it
but I'm happy to do it because here's
the thing about that I like about
Twitter so I don't just give a message i
link if people are interested I try to
back up everything I say with solid
scholarship and link I link to the best
sources I can find or to my own work
that I've done for over the decades
so I link to books and articles if
people are interested so it's it's as if
all of my writing has a new life yeah
and it's also very validating I think to
be in the space that we are when there's
so much misinformation related to
whatever whether it's feminism or
political correctness or anything
there's and there's so many bad actors I
think in this space so it's angry people
yeah but but for us it's nice that we
can be like look here's some information
and then back and go back and forth when
we want and it's it's uh it's very
freeing to me I find and then when I'm
able to connect with like-minded people
I find it to be great I find it great
and all I ever wanted as a college
professor I never saw it as my position
to sort of replicate my view of the
world in the minds of my students heaven
forbid I wanted to open the world to
them show them that the best that was
thought and said on different
contentious issues in metaphysics and
ethics as well as when I was teaching
occasionally would teach gender theory
but when I taught gender theory I found
that there was the the closed mindedness
combined with a kind of a penchant for
conspiracy theories paranoid theories
about the patriarchy that didn't happens
not to exist at least not certainly not
in the United States or Western Europe
and I just I I thought if I had you know
my ideal University I would take I would
have some radicals there because you can
always learn from people that are
pushing the envelope sure but you don't
only have radicals and in gender
scholarship it may be a bit of an
overstatement but I don't think so yeah
really that's all we have okay so before
we get told that let's back up a little
let's just lay out some basic
definitions
because I do find that with a lot of
this people don't even understand what a
feminist is anymore you know you have
your first wave feminists your second
wave feminists third wave feminists now
there's things beyond that that that
you've coined so can you just break down
some of the basic what was the first
feminist movement just give me a couple
great well that would be the suffrage
movement and that was the struggle for
the vote and then after women earned the
vote there was a period of quiescence
and we didn't hear much from feminists
throughout the 30s of 40s the 50s then
it came back in the late 60s early 70s
and that was the second wave and it had
work to do there were a lot of just
arbitrary barriers preventing women
holding women back they needed to be
taken down it was obviously time to do
that and this was stuff more like in the
workforce things like that changing the
workplace changing education addressing
things of you know legally for women to
have more defenses against harassment in
the workplace and so forth all that I
was totally on board that's just basic
quest for equality but what happened is
that the second wave of feminism a lot
of the women in the universities were
quite radical and they were not about
equality they were not about I see
feminism the best of feminism it came
from the European enlightenment and it
was about the intrinsic dignity of all
men and women and extending equality of
opportunity and liberty and so with to
to all they many of them reject the
Enlightenment and they're not about
freedom and freedom of expression and
they are really they use their
classrooms I think to promote a very
rigid worldview about how women are
preyed upon by men and it's almost as if
the as if better things got for women
the more bitter they became and I
watched this from close up because I was
teaching in the university of watching I
kept thinking they would be discredited
because their views will not withstand
20 minutes in a seminar room with some
just objective scholars right but they
do not subject their research to
scrutiny of objective scholars they
they evaluate one another right so there
was this a strange example of where
things could exist sort of in the
academic world where perhaps they
wouldn't these ideas wouldn't have
played out in the real world they didn't
and they I didn't see them in the real
world and I thought they would be
contained in the Academy and then would
go away that has not happened because
partly because of social media and these
Twitter mobs and things that's come into
the mainstream and now we hear their
words like trigger warning we're gonna
get to plenty of that you should be
shooted trigger warning before we sat
down oh we should have yes Isis I am a
walking trigger warning oh do you
consider this a safe space I'm feeling
fairly fairly frequent little micro
aggression gone but not sure ok so then
that was that was second wave feminism
right anyway we evolved into that but
the second wave had a radical extreme
and that extreme became the mean because
they got a monopoly on the
professorships mm-hmm and that's what
you would refer to then as third wave
feminism yeah third way was probably the
intersectional feminism or you know
their various names for it but it's it
didn't correct the excesses of second
wave feminism it took those excesses and
made them even more extreme yeah now
what would you say to the people that
would say well all along that ride even
though even if they were to acknowledge
some of the things that you're saying
all along that ride things basically
were getting better for women so maybe
there was some reasoning behind you know
there was some reasoning but at a
certain point what you had is just
people it was kind of a power grab and
there were women like me Camille poly a
lot of libertarian feminists dissident
feminists we were just disinvited from
the party and students didn't have the
benefit of hearing a range of opinion on
contentious issues take something like
vote something like the wage gap yeah it
if you are an economist and you hear
that group a is earning less than Group
E you know you want to know why they
immediately say discrimination they
blame employers and the patriarchy but
if you do the proper controls than any
competent economist would do and you ask
well how do they differ in any way to
all the men because when you hear that
wage gap they're just doing the average
of all the men in the workplace working
full-time and all the women well men and
women do not study the same top subjects
in college they do not work the same
number of hours men on average work more
hours they take more dangerous jobs
women are far more likely to take a few
years out of the workplace or more these
are relevant to your earnings so then
what happens when we do the proper
controls and there are very good studies
the Labor Department commissioned a
fantastic study that did all the proper
controls it gets to a point where
they're just a few cents you can't
explain now it could be discrimination
and I'm an ex eminent to worry about
that if I cheated out of a few pennies
or webinar but chances are it's not good
chances are it would turn out there's
some innocent explanation yeah so when
it comes to the wage gaps and things
like that so I watched a whole bunch of
videos on it before I watched the video
did it you did on it before this and
partly what I think is what I think when
I watch most political things or almost
anything related to news these days I
never know who to trust right but I
watched these studies that I said this
study well why was it done this way who
funded this who funded that how do you
in the mix of all this figure out what
to actually believe what I do excuse me
as the factual feminist I try to
determine well where is the best source
where's who sets the gold standard for
this research so when it comes to
education nothing surpasses the
Department of Education at the
Department of Education they collect
statistics and they they are very good
when it comes to crime do I believe a
feminist activist that tells me that
we're all you know the majority of women
or a quarter of women are being raped
and assaulted and battered or more it I
go to the Bureau of Justice Statistics
and look at what what do the
statisticians who do careful and highly
disciplined as statistical analyses what
do they find and they find something
very different
yeah they find you rape is a terrible
horrendous crime but it is fairly rare
on the campus it is not one in four and
or one in five and and so I present that
I show people this is what they these
are what sort of objective researchers
have found these are what the advocates
have found now some people just want to
believe the advocates I don't understand
that yeah all right well I do want to
touch on that in a little bit but just
to finish up just sort of the waves of
feminism now you consider yourself and
you coined the phrase I think equity
feminist right can tell people so an
equity feminist I hope you are we all
are is someone who wants for women what
he or she wants for everyone fair
treatment no discrimination
it's basically comes as I said from the
Enlightenment its classical feminism
it's about fairness it doesn't even have
to be called feminism it's probably
humanism or people ISM equal ism and I
that's what I assumed
most people would be for today feminism
it tends to denote people who are
carried away with bail bashing if I had
to reduce it to a few sentences it would
be a women are from Venus and men are
from hell they seem carried away with
with you know female chauvinism I hate
to say it